We are going to talk about
molecular design through
reduced toxicity and how you
go about designing safer
chemicals. Okay. Um,
talked a lot about toxicology
and the basis of toxicology.
And so let's,
uh,
just for a minute or to review what
we knew starting with a principal for.
Um,
so we want to make sure that we preserve
the function of whatever molecules
we're producing while we reduce
toxicity.
And I should say other hazards generally
because we know that toxicity is only
one particular type of hazard.
Alright.
So we're reviewing,
we know that uh,
all hazard is simply based on the physical
chemical properties of a molecule.
Um, in those properties we're
a direct reflection of its,
of its structure,
uh,
and so is subjected to design in
the same way we can design things.
I think I've said to be blue
or red or brittle and flexible.
We can design things to be more or
less toxic. I have to emphasize the,
generally speaking,
why don't you can find anecdotes about
how to do molecular designed to reduce
toxicity.
This is a relatively new area for
systematic scientific investigation.
This is not something that has been a,
uh,
a practice, uh, of, uh,
of chemistry very long.